my contracts up so finally i'm allowed
to do things that i couldn't do before
rules on the spider-man set are to be
taken the most seriously zendaya
brooklyn once and it got her sent off
the set we got in trouble
jacob and i from having to do huge press
tours to restricting water intake not
being allowed to play certain sports
while on contract being part of this
franchise has been no picnic number one
sorry where are you from his american
accent is so good that sometimes we
completely forget he's actually british
and really has pretty much as dreamy an
accent as you can find zendaya knows
what we're talking about your favorite
one is i say yeah he was funny wouldn't
he yeah funny oney considering he did
cross the studio extra when he
accidentally slipped into his natural
accent in a prior film it's no surprise
he'd be extra on the ball and going full
american peter parker like a grandmother
like a grandmother like a grandmother
darling number two just because she was
playing a lead didn't mean she got to be
on set whenever she wanted the actress
was actually specifically called out for
hanging around on set even when she
wasn't filming there's the door there
was a day that i was told cause i was
going to set every day and i was told by
the producers hey just don't come for a
couple days because we you know john's a
little bit behind we don't want any
distractions zendaya obeyed for a while
but what she saw when she came back was
pretty tough to swallow
i walk in the producers
the actors jamie has started a party on
set everybody's dancing to rihanna seems
the rule about not being a distraction
didn't really apply to everyone in this
case so i wasn't allowed to come to work
because there was a distraction and then
i come in and everybody's having a dance
party yeah that was rude it absolutely
was rude how dare you not invite zendaya
to a party number three
you know honestly i think that i don't
want to lose my job so i think if
anything i'm good at like not wanting to
ruin my career wanting to get hired back
is a pretty good reason to not let any
spoilers slip during press interviews
and who's the
worst is that even a question yeah
is it me while everyone tries hard
spider-man himself famously struggles
it's obviously a miracle they let me on
a live tv
as often as he may have accidentally
shared some secret details from the set
it's always been for an innocent reason
here's the thing it's always about tvc
just gets really excited to share
the fun things that are happening number
four
we'll have tom's people call your people
okay so we are about to kick off the
spider-man no way home press tour and
where better to do that than in paris
the work is far from over for this crew
once the cameras stop rolling that's
because the film starts rolling again in
interview studios while journalists
capture all the info possible about the
movie i'm a bit under the weather today
so i could have used an extra hour in
bed whether they like it or not it's a
no questions asked part of the gig it
definitely takes a long time to get used
to and i gotta be honest i still don't
think it's something that i'm used to
number five being a hero off screen
takes special skills it's super crazy
spoiler sense yeah that's what it is
i've got good stuff you got a
development no matter how they're
feeling when the studio requires these
actors to be on they've got to show up
tom holland is a superhero on screen but
that can't happen unless he behaves the
same way in real life which can be
particularly tricky when it comes to
pushier journalists
developed
an ability to spot tactics from
journalists trying to get stuff out of
us real talk they have absolutely nailed
their spoiler sense in the no way home
press tour what was the funniest
spider-man scene to shoot
i i can't say the funniest day
um you can't say that i can't can't say
the most heartwarming scene i know
we all know are you really thinking
about this well no i'm trying to think
i'm trying to think of a scene that i
can talk about
oh i can't speak on that can i yeah it's
tough solid work team number six what's
that smell a three week old spidey suit
and it's not cute it's
[Music]
stunning
the fact is having to wear the spidey
spandex for about eighty percent of
filming made for a very sweaty time
the whole stinging costume at all times
rule was especially brutal the last five
weeks of filming since holland sported
the look the entire time i think the
worst thing about playing spider-man is
the
lack of toilet breaks i get because the
suit is so tight right and we all know
how long it takes me to take it on and
off it's not just holland affected by
the all costumes all the time rule
though it provides a whole lot of extra
work for the costume department too i
will wear a suit and i'll wear that suit
for three weeks and then i'll have to
build a new suit because it gets torn to
pieces and my poor costumer every time
it's a new suit is like i'm really sorry
because putting a new one on takes ages
number seven wake up work go home repeat
holland has a major responsibility as
the one who gets to play the peter
parker and while it's not officially in
his contract the actor has to consider
how he spends his time offset very
carefully that's the worst thing i've
ever put in my mouth i've been very
careful over the years with what i've
been doing outside of work which is why
i've become a perfect golf because it's
the only sport i can play without
getting injured an injury would cause
filming delays which would then cause a
very upset production studio my
contract's up finally i'm allowed to do
things that i couldn't do before like as
soon as i finished i went snowboarding i
have an amazing photo of me facetiming
you with blood all over my face i
answered the phone you just covered it
what are you doing everyone was like
wipe it off i was like no i look cool
number eight yo what do you lift bro
this was for you dad
he needs to be a great actor and a
full-time athlete before even getting to
set super tom hits the gym to get into
the right headspace and energy to
spider-man all day i mean when i say
there's like blood sweat and tears i'm
not exaggerating making these films is
incredibly tough it makes sense after
all how awkward would it be if
spider-man wasn't actually able to um
you know spider
number nine some days he's just gotta be
spidey all the time since holland's
spider-man head is a complicated setup
including a helmet rigged up with hot
battery packs and cooling fans that
never actually work he's not allowed to
take it off to eat or drink on set
there's a hole underneath the eye socket
where we used to be able to feed a tube
down and i could drink without taking
the suit off this frappuccino snap is
actually a great reminder of the fact
that spider-man isn't all superhero all
the time milk and sugar we're talking
about the same zip right a toilet
number 10 staying hydrated drinking your
egg cups a day
however you look at it drinking water
regularly is important but it's a big
no-go for tom holland the spidey suit is
simply too tricky to change in and out
of quickly enough so needing to go to
the bathroom as infrequently as possible
was the key to success even after
multiple successful films the production
team hasn't tried to make this tricky
rule any easier to deal with and i asked
for a zip and i didn't get one number 11
no voice no choice yikes no doubt these
actors know their characters extremely
well and while this brings a lot to the
table at the end of the day there really
is just one head honcho john is great at
being collaborative yeah he always wants
our input and our thoughts which is
really special but i also think that he
kind of already had a master plan in the
end of it no matter how the actors feel
they've got to say those words they're
given luckily the creative team makes
such solid choices that it's pretty easy
to obey this rule
number 12 you get a mask and you get a
mask and you get a mask
the spider-man mask does not count as
ppe
so i have to wear two masks it wasn't
just spider-man's face who was hidden
behind a mask the whole global pandemic
thing meant everyone was in masks all
the time we get tested every day we have
a great team of people the kobe team you
were there testing us they've done a
fantastic job
all this plus social distancing and a
light safety system all of course added
time to the production but ultimately it
was what needed to happen to make sure
this movie got made
we have got to give this crew credit
their commitment level is through the
roof but hey that's what it takes to be
a model superhero on and off screen rule
number five remember